هذه هي
أول مراجعة لنا للسيارة soyuz ms-18 الآن
حوالي تسع دقائق ونصف حتى
هبوط المزلق الرئيسي نشر
كل شيء بالكامل أه في الوقت المحدد
، أبلغ الطاقم أنهم يشعرون بصحة جيدة
، حيث يتم نقل البيانات عن بعد والصوت من
خلال antonoff ثابت-  طائرات
الهليكوبتر الروسية من طراز mi-8 في موقع الهبوط الآن في
نمط مضمار السباق جاهزة لاستقبال
الطاقم بعد الهبوط
الذي تعرفه
[موسيقى]
في ثانية ،
هذا هو
فريق البحث والإنقاذ
16 و 17 في الأول والثاني والثامن
و  نسختان
ممتازتان
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
ثماني دقائق حتى هبوط كل شيء
أه يسير أه بطريقة جيدة جدًا
، سيوز ms-18 oleg novitskiy قائد soyuz
في المقعد الأوسط يحيط
به إلى يساره
المخرج الروسي كليم شيبينكو
وعلى يمينه الممثلة الروسية
يوليا باريسيلد على
بعد دقائق فقط من العودة إلى
الأرض والهبوط على بعد 92 ميلًا إلى
الجنوب الشرقي من مدينة جيزكاسغان ، إنه
صباح الأحد على خطوة كاز
سماء صافية بأخستان ، رياح خفيفة ، درجات
حرارة منخفضة إلى منتصف الأربعينيات
[موسيقى]
مشددة على ظهرك ، نعم
محكم للغاية ،
493 هو الضغط والنمو
الجيد
[الموسيقى] على
بعد دقائق من إكمال مهمة 191 يومًا
تمتد على 80.9 مليون ميل.
مشاهد مصورة لفيلم على متن
محطة الفضاء الدولية
خلال الـ 12 يومًا الماضية
والعودة إلى الأرض ،
تشاهد إحدى طائرات الهليكوبتر الروسية mi8
أه تحلق أه في الجزء
الأمامي
من كتيبة
أصول rosavayatsa جاهزة لاستعادة
الطاقم
بمجرد حدوث هبوط.  يستغرق
الأمر بضع دقائق فقط
حتى يتمكن فريق البحث والاسترداد من
إحاطة الكبسولة
بإقامة خيمة طبية قابلة للنفخ
والبدء في عملية إخراج الطاقم
من وحدة النسب
[موسيقى]
كيف
ومن هم هؤلاء الأشخاص
[موسيقى] لقد
ربطت حقًا  لقد ربطت الأشرطة الخاصة بي
كما لو أنني شدتها كثيرًا
، لا بأس بذلك
[موسيقى] ،
حسنًا
220 هو الارتفاع و 555 هو
وحدة
البحث عن الضغط والإنقاذ في وحدة النسب  لا يمكن فهم الصوت ،
هل ترى
هل ترى المروحية ، لا ،
أنا
لست نظيفًا ،
أنت تقترب من ارتفاع 200 متر
[موسيقى]
16.16 على بعد
أقل من 200 متر من
الأرض ، سيستعد الطاقم قريبًا
لإطلاق النار في الهبوط الهادئ  المحركات على
بعد بضعة أقدام فقط من الأرض ،
المعلومات التي يتم نقلها إلى
أجهزة الكمبيوتر الموجودة على متن الطائرة بواسطة مقياس الارتفاع في
قاعدة soyuz ،
لا نحصل عليها ، يستغرق ارتفاع شخصين
[موسيقى]
1600 والضغط اللائق للوحدة هو 603.
ويمكننا أن
نؤكد
1600.
إذا أدرت رأسك قليلاً ،
فهل ترى
هل تراهم لا ،
ربما لا يكونون في صفك
للبحث والإنقاذ جيدًا ، والأهم من ذلك
يمكننا رؤيتكم يا رفاق
الذين يبحثون وينقذون
حسنًا ، الكاميرا أيضًا تسجل حتى
نتمكن من رؤيتها لاحقًا
1200 هو
الارتفاع ونؤكد
أه الارتفاع ألف ومئتان
وستة عشر
قمع ستة
عشر ويؤكسد 0.8 و 1.4
نقوم بنسخ
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] على
نحو سلس للغاية  النزول تحت المظلة الرئيسية
سرعان ما يستعد الطاقم للهبوط
[موسيقى] ،
كل الرجال المناسبين
يطويون ذراعيك بإحكام
ويستعدون فقط
لنشر إطلاق النار ،
نراكم يا رفاق ،
هذا هو فريق البحث والإنقاذ ،
كل شيء اسمي
ستة وسبعة وخمسة هو
ضغط الوحدة
المناسب
مثل الارتفاع  500 متر استعدوا
يا شباب نسخة
[موسيقى]
استعدوا
لا تتحدثوا حتى أخبركم أن
400 نسخة من الارتفاع
[موسيقى]
الارتفاع 300 متر نسخة
100 متر يستعد الرجال للوقوف
عند الهبوط على
مسافة 550 مترًا
[موسيقى]
تم تأكيد 20 مترًا من الرجال
يستعدون
للهبوط في الساعة 11 و 35 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي
12 و 35 صباحًا بالتوقيت الشرقي
10 و 35 صباحًا بتوقيت كازاخستان
أوليج نوفيتسكي المنزل بعد 191 يومًا في
الفضاء ليوليا باريسيلد وكليم
شيبينكو هبطوا عموديًا رائعًا
وتأكيدًا من قوات البحث
والانتعاش  أن السويوز هبطت في
وضع مستقيم ، لذا فقد توقفوا عن الهبوط على
خطوة كازاخستان ،
وهي مهمة صناعة الأفلام لمدة 12 يومًا من
باراسيلت وتشابينكو في نهاية
يا
[موسيقى]
عائلتي
هبوط سلس لـ nowitzki
paraceled و shipenko على خطوة
كازاخستان في صباح أحد أيام الأحد
، تجبر عناصر البحث والانتعاش
المروحيات الروسية من طراز mi-8
ومركبات جميع التضاريس الآن على التحرك
نحو الكبسولة
لبدء عملية نصب
نفخ.  خيمة طبية
واستخراج الطاقم
، سيتم وضعهم على الكراسي
بجوار الكبسولة
مباشرة لبضع دقائق لإعادة
التأقلم مع جاذبية الأرض
قبل إحضارهم إلى تلك
الخيمة الطبية للخروج من انطلاقهم الاجتماعي الروسي
وبدلات الدخول
والارتداء بشكل أكثر راحة.  الملابس
قبل أن يستقلوا المروحيات ليطيروا
حوالي ساعتين إلى مدينة الانطلاق في
كاراجاندا
حيث سيصعدون على متن
طائرة مركز تدريب رائد فضاء غاغارين في
رحلة العودة إلى قاعدتهم التدريبية في
ستار سيتي روسيا خارج موسكو ،
كل الأحداث على
مدار أه  ذهب العصر والمساء أه
حسب جدول
توديع الطاقم لنظرائهم في المحطة الفضائية
التسلق على متن سيارتهم soyuz ms-18
وإجراء فحوصات التسرب
لبدلاتهم الفضائية ومركبتهم
قبل فصل soyuz من وحدة
Naoka للمحطة الفضائية الدولية ،
وحدة
المختبر متعددة الأغراض
التي تحدث في الساعة 8 14 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي
9 14 مساءً بالتوقيت الشرقي
الذي استغرقه حرق deorbit
ضع
كما هو مخطط له إطلاقًا رجعيًا مدته أربع دقائق و 38 ثانية
لإبطاء سويوز
مما يسمح له بالخروج من المدار
وبعد 54 دقيقة من العودة للوطن مع
هبوط السويوز على خطوة
كازاخستان ،
ترى الآن
كتيبة من المركبات تشق طريقها
نحو أه  الكبسولة نفسها
التي رأيت نزول السويوز تحت
هبوط المظلة الرئيسي لها
قبل بضع دقائق فقط في الساعة 11 35 مساءً
بالتوقيت المركزي
12 35 صباحًا بالتوقيت الشرقي
10 35 صباحًا في كازاخستان صباح أحد أيام الأحد ،
لذا فإن
[موسيقى
]  مركز التحكم في المهمة هيوستن ، سنكون على
أهبة الاستعداد لمشاهدة
المزيد
من مقاطع الفيديو من موقع الهبوط ، حيث
تشاهد صورة حية
من كاميرا على مركبة لجميع التضاريس  cle التي
تتبعت هبوط سويوز تحت
مظلتها الرئيسية
للدقائق الأخيرة من مهمتها
بعد أن خرجت من محطة الفضاء الدولية في
وقت سابق من هذا المساء
، وأجرت حرقًا في المدار وهبوطًا في الوقت المحدد
في الساعة 10 11 و 35 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي 10 35 صباحًا
بتوقيت كازاخستان في  موقع الهبوط في
صباح يوم الأحد
، أفاد تقرير من قوات البحث
والإنقاذ أن السويوز هبطت في وضع مستقيم ،
لذلك سيتم استخراج الطاقم من
خلال استخدام سلم سيتم
تثبيته على طول جانب الكبسولة
، وستكون الفتحة العلوية للسيوز  open
and uh سيعمل أعضاء
فرق الطاقة والبحث والاسترداد
على استخراج أفراد الطاقم
واحدًا تلو الآخر
[موسيقى]
لذا
[موسيقى]  ]
[موسيقى]
هذا هو مركز التحكم بالمهمة
يواصل مشاهدة
مقطع فيديو من موقع الهبوط
على خطوة كازاخستان إلى
الجنوب الشرقي من مدينة جيزكاسغان
حيث هبطت المركبة الفضائية soyuz ms-18
على بعد حوالي 13 مترًا  قبل
inutes ، أكمل هبوطًا لا تشوبه شائبة إلى
الغلاف الجوي للأرض بعد خروجها
من محطة الفضاء الدولية قبل
بضع ساعات
أوليغ نوفيتسكي إلى المنزل بعد 191 يومًا في
الفضاء
الآن مع إجمالي 531 يومًا في الفضاء في
ثلاث بعثاته
الممثلة الروسية يوليا باريشيلد
والمنتجة.  عاد المخرج كليم شيبينكو
إلى الأرض بعد 12 يومًا
على متن
المحطة التي صوروا فيها مشاهد لفيلم
بعنوان التحدي ،
لذا فإن
محطة [موسيقى] [موسيقى] على 2 لتلفزيون vme ،
انطلق إلى محطة
مرحبًا ، آه ، ساعات الليل الأولى.
مهمة مراقبة هيوستن حوالي 20
دقيقة منذ هبوط الطائرة soyuz
ms-18 على عتبة كازاخستان
وما زلنا أه ننتظر
إعادة تموضع كاميرات التليفزيون
والمركبات الصالحة لجميع التضاريس
بواسطة
الكبسولة ونتوقع استقبال
تليفزيوني إضافي هنا
للحظة أه الآن  استقبال هذا التلفاز
حيث أه تم إعداد الأخير
في الكبسولة
لبدء عملية إخراج
الطاقم
وضع السماعة على
ما يرام.
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، اهدأ الجميع
تلك هي الكراسي التي تم وضعها
أه من
الكبسولة التي سيوضع عليها أفراد الطاقم الثلاثة
أولي نوفيتسكي جوليا باريس
الممثلة
ومخرجها كليم
تشابينكو ، سيتم استخراجهم واحدًا تلو الآخر
من الفتحة العلوية للسيوز
بعد هبوطها في الوقت المحدد في الساعة 11 35
مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي
10 35 صباحًا بتوقيت كازاخستان
في صباح أحد أيام الأحد ، وكما ترون
سماء صافية
تقريبًا لا رياح في موقع الهبوط ،
درجات الحرارة في الأربعينيات
تكاد تكون مثالية  لعودة
أعضاء الطاقم الثلاثة ،
سأعطيك تلميحًا
حسنًا ، من فضلك لا ينبغي لأحد أن ينظر
إلى الكاميرا
من هو الممثل هنا ،
سأعلن نعم لأننا قد لا نتمكن من القيام بذلك
لاحقًا ،
حسنًا ، كل شيء على ما يرام
أه الناس يقفون هنا  يرجى
إزالة الأقنعة للجميع ،
شكرًا لك
، هل أنت مستعد ،
وتأكد من عدم بقاء أي شخص في القناع ومساعدة
بعضه البعض
، ووضعت أوليج نوفيتسكي في
كرسيه
بعد أن تم استخراجه من soyuz
w  هل هبطت في وضع مستقيم ،
هل يمكننا الاقتراب
من القائد الروسي المخضرم الآن
مع 531 يومًا في الفضاء لحسابه
لا تتدخل لا تخطو على البلاستيك الأزرق
لإصلاحه مثل هذا
قليلاً مثل ما
[موسيقى]
أعضاء rsc  يعمل فريق Inergia الفني
وموظفو دعم البحث والاسترداد
الآن أه لاستخراج
عضوين آخرين من الطاقم يوليا باريسيلد
وكليم شيبينكو في
الوقت نفسه أوليج نوفيتسكي
في صباح أحد أيام الأحد ،
حيث يتم إجراء الاختبارات الطبية الأولية التي يتم إجراؤها
في حالة جيدة بعد أن
أكملت 191 يومًا في الفضاء
على هذا  المهمة التي امتدت 80.9
مليون ميل
[موسيقى]
وأه المخرج المنتج كليم تشابينكو
الآن خارج soyuz
حسنًا ، ها أنت إلى المنزل
حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
اهدأ
بحذر ، واستمر في التحرك دون
خطوة بعيدًا
، واه لحظات بعيدًا عن رؤية يوليا
paracelled
هي soyuz ms-18 تهبط في وضع مستقيم أه في
الوقت المحدد في الساعة 11 35 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي 10 35 صباحًا
بتوقيت كازاخستان
واه هناك يوليا بارسيلد
الممثلة الروسية الآن خرجت من مركبة سويوز ،
حسنًا ،
أين أنتم
يا رفاق ، دعنا نطلق بعض النار
على حشد كبير إلى حد ما لتحية هذا الثلاثي
العائد من الفضاء بما في ذلك
رئيس روسكوزموس ديميتري روجوزين ،
هل أعجبك ذلك ،
حسنًا ، هذا هو
الآن يرجى من الجميع
التراجع إلى
حيث  هل سيكون لدى
جميع أفراد الطاقم الثلاثة خارج
سويوز بضع دقائق للاستمتاع بضوء
شمس صباح الأحد ،
سيتم نقلهم قريبًا
إلى الخيمة الطبية القابلة للنفخ المجاورة
للخروج من بدلات الإطلاق
والدخول الاجتماعية الروسية وارتداء ملابس أكثر راحة.
بعد أن تسلمت الممثلة الروسية باقة من
الزهور ، سيتم نقلها
في ثلاث طائرات هليكوبتر روسية من طراز MI-8
إلى كاراجندا كازاخستان بعد وقت قصير
من الآن
على متن طائرة مركز تدريب رائد فضاء غاغارين
في رحلة العودة إلى
ستار سيتي روسيا خارج موسكو
[  موسيقى]
نحن قريبون جدًا من
إنسان خارق كانت جوليا جوليا
تطير إلى الفضاء
وكيف كان الأمر رائعًا
حسنًا
غير مسموع
خطوة للوراء
باستثناء مجموعة الدعم ،
سيتم نقل أفراد طاقم سويوز الثلاثة
قريبًا إلى الخيمة الطبية القابلة للنفخ في
مكان قريب ،
واستعدوا
يا رفاق ، من فضلك لا تفعل
أي تصوير على
الهواتف الذكية الخاصة بك ،
لا تأخذ أي مقاطع فيديو لأن
هذا هو المستقبل بالفعل.
نهاية الفيلم
أه في
الواقع
كان هناك
بعض المساحة في
نموذج النزول لأنه كان
لديه لحظة للدردشة مع أحد
أعضاء البحث والاسترداد يجبر ممرضة روسية
إلى جانبه وهذا أمر معتاد لجميع
أفراد طاقم soyuz العائدين للحصول على أه
الدعم الروسي  طاقم طبي بما في ذلك
الطاقم الطبي للحضور إليهم
عند عودتهم ، سأراكم قريبًا جدًا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لكم
ونظرة أخرى
على الممثلة الروسية يوليا باريسيلد التي أمضت 12 يومًا
على متن محطة الفضاء الدولية
مع مخرجها المنتج كليم تشابينكو
[موسيقى]
اركض
وأنتظر بسرعة
ما
هو التأخير في
تغيير البطارية؟
تعيد أه
أرجلها الأرضية
إلى خطوة كازاخستان أه
جزء من طاقم الفيلم المرتبط
بتحدي الفيلم أه الذي ظهر
طفيليًا كجراح يطير إلى
محطة الفضاء
لحضور أحد أفراد الطاقم المريض
الذي صورته نوفيتسكي على
متن الفيلم  يقوم الطاقم بتصوير مشاهد إضافية
في موقع الهبوط
قبل نقل الطاقم إلى
الخيمة الطبية القريبة للخروج من
إطلاق دائرتهم وبدلات الدخول ،
حسنًا ، استمع إلي ،
لا
يجب أن يبتعد فلاديمير
عن أوليج قبل
أن يطلب
[موسيقى]  المصافحة أولاً ثم يتجه
نحو فيرجينيا ،
حسنًا ، سأكون هنا ،
لا تركع واقفًا أولاً ،
يرجى
وضع جميع هواتفك الذكية بعيدًا ،
واستعد
لبدء التشغيل ،
هل نحتاج إلى شخص آخر ،
يعيد الجميع إلى مواقع معينة ،
مرة أخرى ،
الخيار الثاني
الخيار الثاني هو أن الجميع مستعد
حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
بداية رائعة
واحدة أخرى لنفعلها
سريعًا ،
استعد الجميع
كاميرون
[موسيقى]
هذا هوست التحكم في المهمة  على
الاستمرار في مشاهدة أه
مناظر حية من موقع الهبوط في
كازاخستان
مع طاقم soyuz ms-18
الذي عاد لتوه
من وقتهم في محطة الفضاء الدولية
ما يحدث هنا هو أن أه
فيلم التحدي
هناك مشاهد هنا بعد الهبوط
وهي  يجري تصويرها من
أجل أه في الفيلم
خاصةً مع يوليا باراسيل
الممثلة الروسية التي تراها
هناك ولديهم العديد من اللقطات
كما في فيلم ، حيث
من الواضح أن الطاقم في حالة معنوية جيدة
وفي حالة جيدة تدعم كل ذلك
تحت  العين الساهرة
للممرضات الروس وغيرهم من موظفي البحث والإنعاش
، يبدو الآن بعد أن كان لديهم
العديد من الأشياء
الجيدة ، سيتم إحضار الطاقم قريبًا إلى
خيمة طبية قريبة
لأه
التقييمات الطبية بعد الهبوط
لتغيير ملابس أكثر راحة
ثم الطيران  في مروحيات العودة إلى
مدينة الانطلاق في كاراجندا
كازاخستان والآن الطاقم كما ترون
يتم نقله بعيدًا عن موقع
الهبوط بالقرب من تي  الكبسولة الوريثة نحو ساعة
الخيمة الطبية تلك
تثير أي
غبار يحمله مخرج المنتج
الآن نحو موقع آخر بالقرب من
الكبسولة ،
والجميع يتراجع إلى الوراء ، ونهنئك
على عودتك إلى المنزل ويسعدنا
جدًا رؤيتك
أجنبيًا
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك ،
يرجى تقديم
حسنًا ، باختصار ، نحتاج إلى التوقف عن السؤال
وإلا فلن يوقف نفسه مطلقًا
[موسيقى]
هل قلت ذلك غير مسموع لأنه
كان صعبًا للغاية ،
حسنًا ، نحتاج إلى اختتام الأمر على
الجميع الآن خطوة إلى الوراء
الآن صورة جماعية
[موسيقى]
مع olek
ولكن  القائد أولاً
[موسيقى]
لنا العام المقبل
حسنًا
[موسيقى]
يبدو كما لو أن الطاقم سيتم
نقله الآن نحو
الخيمة الطبية بعد اكتمال تصوير بعض
المشاهد لتحدي الفيلم ،
نعم ، يرجى أخذ هذا
الآن  تم إجراء القياس الثاني الأول
هنا ،
هذا
تقليد روسي
لجعل قائد soyuz يوقع
خارج مركبته الفضائية ،
أوه
لا يزال
يتعين علينا ركوب
هذه
المركبة ، غادر القائد  توقيعه
جوليا ، أنت الأفضل على
ما يرام ،
دعنا نقترب من وحدة النسب
، أعذرنا والآن نويتسكي الآن في
الخيمة الطبية قريبًا
ليتبعه perisild and chapenko
[موسيقى]
أوه
لطيفة
[موسيقى]
نعم ، الممثلة يوليا باريسيلد الآن على وشك
دخول الخيمة الطبية
[موسيقى]
ويتم الآن نقل كليم شابينكو
نحو الخيمة الطبية
[موسيقى]
انظروا إلى هذا
الأجنبي ،
لذا فإن أعضاء الطاقم الثلاثة
أوليج نوفيتسكي جوليا باريسيلد وكليم تشابينكو
الآن أه في الخيمة
الطبية للخروج من إطلاق دائرتهم
وبدلات دخولهم وارتداء ملابس أكثر راحة
قبل
تحميلهم على طائرات هليكوبتر روسية من طراز mi-8
لرحلة العودة إلى مدينة الانطلاق في
كاراجندا كازاخستان
حيث
سيصعدون على متن رائد فضاء روسي من غاغارين  طائرات مركز
التدريب لرحلة العودة إلى ستار سيتي روسيا
وقاعدة التدريب الخاصة بهم
حتى مع عودة جميع أفراد الطاقم الثلاثة بأمان
إلى الأرض وفي الخيمة الطبية في
موقع الهبوط في كازاخستان
سارت عملية الهبوط
كما يمكن أن
يتوقعها الكتاب بعض عمليات إعادة الهبوط
التي رأيتها سابقًا في تغطيتنا الحية
لعودة soyuz
ms-18
مع حدوث الهبوط
في الساعة 11 35 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي 12 35
صباحًا شرقًا.  الساعة 10 35 صباحًا في
موقع الهبوط في كازاخستان في صباح يوم الأحد ،
تختتم نوفيتسكي
191 يومًا على محطة الفضاء الدولية
الآن 531 يومًا في الفضاء في
ثلاث بعثات
باراسيل في تشابينكو
لتوسيع بُعد جديد في تسويق الفضاء من
خلال
قضاء 12 يومًا في المحطة المدارية
تصوير فيلم
بعنوان التحدي الذي
صور فيه أحد أبناء الرعية جراحًا يحضر أحد
أفراد الطاقم المريض
هنا ، حيث تم إطلاق طائرة باراسليد
في تشيبينكو في الخامس من أكتوبر على soyuz tm على
مركبة الفضاء soyuz ms-19 التي لا تزال في
محطة الفضاء الدولية
مع قائدها  أنتون شكابليروف
الآن جزء من طاقم البعثة 66
شكابليروف للعودة إلى الأرض في المسيرة القادمة
مع مارك فانديهي
ورائد الفضاء الروسي
piotr dubrov حتى نختتم تغطيتنا
الليلة بهبوط آمن لـ soyuz ms-18
وأفراد طاقمها الثلاثة
نوفيتسكي باريس وتشابينكو بأمان
إلى الأرض ،
شكرًا لانضمامك إلينا
طوال اليوم والمساء.
أتمنى لك عطلة نهاية أسبوع
رائعة وهذا كل شيء الآن
للتحكم في المهمة في هيوستن
[موسيقى]
العديد من الطيارين اليوم لا يخرجون
بقلق فوري على رحلتهم من
أنهم سيصطدمون بالأرض
فهناك مشكلة في الطيران
الرحلة التي يتم التحكم فيها عن طريق التضاريس الداخلية التي يتم
التحكم فيها في التضاريس
هي حالة